okay welcome everyone to the second talk
of the series on boolean function method
today we are pleased to have a fantastic
talk with two speakers how hung and I
wish I thought so how got his PhD from
the Ephraim UCLA and his help
postdoctoral positions at IAS and
dementia instead of umn and he's now a
currently at freedom in track faculty at
Emory University how you found ingenious
and surprising proof of a long-standing
one of the long biggest open questions
in boolean function Alice's last year
and today we'll hear about the proof and
in the second half of the talk we'll
have a wish I will tell us about its
applications to query complexity and
some of his recent work on quantum query
complexity and deterministic very
complexity and before we start the talk
there's a disc or channel which is which
one could use for two for discussions
and questions also the question answer
stream on the on zoom' will be looking
at questions there so please write down
all the questions that you might have
there and the there's a mailing list
that we have created for reminders for
this talk series we will if you'd like
to be added to that mailing list we'll
send out an email to this off afternoon
to everyone who's attending the talk
today and you could just add yourself to
the mailing list that way all right so
let's start okay so first of all I would
like to thank resign obviously for
organizing this square was up and
inviting me to speak in it so today I'm
going to talk about basically the
background motivation in the
you can judge and I think the second
part the talk I would say we'll talk
about some recent applications so I
guess we the name of the worst service
about boolean functions we're all
familiar with the definition bit if not
let me mention this one more time
so a boolean function is just a function
then mass n dimensional binary stream to
0 of 1 so here we introduce the
definition of sensitivity so first we do
it locally so was the local sensitivity
of a boolean function f on the input
packs so here X is just a given in
dimensional binary stream f is a given
boolean function so we just want to
count the number coordinates I such that
f of X is not equal to f of X pi so here
the notation X I means we flip the ice
coordinate of X so basically we look out
a given point X how many coordinates
with a change such that it changes the
value of the function f at this point
and the sensitivity of this boolean
function is just defined as the maximum
locally here the maximum is taken over
all the N dimensional binary States so
let's see a very easy clamp the end
function in n variables so in August 1
if all the inputs are equal to 1 and
obviously low if any one inputs you go
to the yellow so here the for simplicity
I don't want to discuss the trivial case
for n is equal to vs. in a large now is
the sensitivity of F at 0 input so ok so
f of 0 is equal to 0 but if you change
any one coordinate from 0 to 1
you still get 0 right so no cordemais
sensitive at this input so the
sensitivity is equal to 0 and on the
other hand if you look at the all 1
input the sensitivity is equal to 1
because for one vector is Matt - what
but even I mean it may be changed one
coordinate from 1 to 0 is mapped to 0 up
now ok so now what's the sensitivity the
global sensitivity of this and fauns
so you go to the maximum but obviously
cannot exceed a number very
so it's equal to head exactly so I hope
this example is good enough for this
definition of sensitivity so let me move
on to a different concept called the
block sensitivity so this tool slice
looks pretty similar but that totally
two different slides so was the local
Plaza Nativity first so instead of
flipping one chord in their tongue now
we would like a big block of coordinates
so here blow just mean a subset of
coordinate so it doesn't have to be
consecutive coordinates so now for fixed
input X we'd like to maximize the number
of decision success we won't be two up
to VK so slip the intercepts NPI
this changes the value of f and
similarly we just defy the global
process the committee as the maximum
local process City BT so again let's
look at the end of function
now you can see looks all similar sorry
for the all one input the answer is 10
because if you change any bit the values
change from 1 to 0 but now for the audio
input actually the process it local
processivity is equal to 1 because you
can change the entire and M coordinates
and the value not changes and so what's
the global prosody tivity is still equal
to 10 because it's the mess in one and
you cannot exceed n now from this
examples you can already see that the
process atiba T is always greater or
equal to the sensitivity why because if
you fix the input X then if you have
let's say T coordinates they're
sensitive you can always stay this T
coordinates as the blocks in the
definition of the local proximity well
the local Plus activity is always
greater or equal to the local
sensitivity and we maximize the
inequality but at this woman we have
seen only the N function if you do the
orphans you can see that also the
sensitivity and the process activity are
both equal to 10 if you play with some
small examples you see the assumes that
they're always equal but as you do it
really need to introduce two different
definitions and are they always equal
they insisted on right that's why they
have different names and let me show you
a function such that the placenta V T is
literally greater than the sensitivity
and this is the famous Rubenstein
function so now let me define boolean
function f in n squared error box so N
is a positive integer so you can think
of it in this way so you have n rows and
n columns so the n square variables and
let me call this X IJ so I am runs from
1 to M so first of all for every row I
define a function G in this way so if
you have the first and the second
coordinate will be post equal to 1 and
the rest of the coordinates to be 0
or if you have the second the third
coordinate would be 1 and the other
coordinates would be yellow or cetera
then she out goes one so ok so G ops 1
if and only if you see two consecutive
coordinates gives that gives you 1 and
now for every row you've applied the G
function and after you get output from
every room then you'll pay the whole
function now I claim that the process
atiba T of this boolean function the
rubenstein function is called L is
quadratic in there why is that so if I
don't always take a look at this 4x4
case so let's only focus on the input 0
the all-0 vector
so if Paris is the low and of course
chuckle zero so every rock zero and if
you take all function it still gives it
zero now if you just change the first
two coordinates on the first row from 0
to 1 then the first loss of Y right by
definition of G now once you see one in
one of the rows then you must here one
in the final output so changing these
two coordinates from 0 to 1 changes the
value of F but similarly you can keep
these two coordinates to be 0 and change
the next two coordinates we can transmit
these two coordinates on the second role
in film so basically for the 0 input you
can find la 3 and square
over two blocks suspect there are
disputes of them are sensitive so the
processor divot is at least roughly ten
square over two now on the other hand we
can show that the sensitivity is at most
linear in ten why is that so let's
discuss two different cases
that's a yellow input and the one input
so this is a question so that's Jay in
the Rubinstein function need to be
unique or there could be multiple source
consecutive so there cannot be multiples
of J because let's go back to the
definition because we need these two
coordinates to be worn in the rest to be
zero but of course on different rows you
can have different different chase okay
so now let me move on to the sensitivity
so at the zero input so now because we
are taking the all function over the
road so we know that every Lomas output
zero and now I'm claiming that for every
row that at most two sensitive coding
that's because in the worst case you
have a binary stream like this you have
one coordinates equal to 1 at the rest
equal to zero so if you change this
coordinate would please laugh or this
coordinate who is right then it changes
the value of this function so every role
is at most two sensitive coordinates and
the only handbook so that at most two x
coordinates so the local sensitivity of
F this input X is at most two times K
now let's look at the X where F of S is
equal to one so if we're not here to
have already at least two rows the
output 1 then we can immediately
conclude that the sense it the local
sensitivity and this input is equal to
zero because when you can only change
one coordinate it will only change at
most one and most output of one role but
you will not affect avenge eventual
value of your thoughts okay so the
sensitivity local sentiment in this case
is equal to this year
on the other hand if you have only one
load output one so you can see the other
rows doesn't matter you cannot have any
sensitive coordinates from the other
rows so even if this row has every chord
it made to be sensitive you get at most
n sensitive coded so in this case you
get a local sensitivity to be at most n
so in both cases you have a linear upper
top
so okay so let me quickly summarize this
so we know that for every real function
f the sensitivity is bounded from above
by the block sensitivity and this
Rubenstein's example shows that there
exists a boolean function f such that is
plus sensitivity is quadratic in the
sensitivity so thus plus an xx p.m. the
number plus no I mean there are some
definitions okay process itty-bitties
and so but but here you can take this
number plus to the average server all
right so so we have a sensitivity that I
can you send it again and plus acitivity
and so these are 0 input boolean you
know capability low input for this time
[Music]
let's see ok so yeah so I will roll
output 0 yes and now if you change one
row from right but there's no sensitive
code in a in this case I guess you see
because if you change the first 0 to 1
then I mean it was no still no I mean
there's no local sensitivities equal to
T's input okay so as I said we know that
sensitivity is a most applause
sensitivity and processing it really
could be quality sensitivity in some
cases and there was this beautiful
congestion is a gigantic in 1992 there
are seas it should
for every boolean function f the process
activities bounded from above by
sensitivity to the power of C for some
positive constant C and now even ask the
following question so I mean a
sensitivity is definitely a very natural
measuring the complexity of a boolean
function so for example if instead of
looking at sensitivity you instead of
taking the maximum local sensitivity you
look at every slow call sensitivity then
this is the influence that the total
influence that you may have heard from
the previous lectures but why do you
even care about the look unnatural nose
and the reason is because so actually
the process any TBT is closely related
to a lot of other complexity measures of
boolean functions there are theoretical
in the scientists care about so to stay
this probably let me first define what
does it mean for two complexity measures
to be polynomially related so it just
means that you can just bound let's say
for every boolean function as one apply
or math is always great or you could ask
to add some positive 1s body from above
but as true positive so if function is
complicated in one manner there has to
be complicated well in the other meant
so has been wrong note that the falling
leaves of complexity measures of boolean
functions are normally related so this
includes the boss sensitivity which was
discussed and the deterministic
resiliency complexity certificate
capacity so let me sell it'll be above
water decrease because that's the notion
that I'm going to use later so for every
boolean function there is a unique way
of writing it was a multi linear point
of view and the degree of that real
multi linear polynomial is just the
degree of this boolean function so for
yong-chol you can check that the end
function and function and variables both
sat agree and there's also another
notion called approximate degree of F
and this randomized person and quantum
version of query complexity so
I mean with no up-tempo Nomi related we
haven't determined all the best tungsten
we can get in his polynomial relations
but the men are standing problem in this
field before 2019 was is the sensitivity
also Buster sensitivity also belong to
this list and so as an annuity can just
basically says that well if to it this
sensitivity will cease to be our life
and joins a large and heavy flow
according to Scott Aaronson but there
also some first aspect of the
sensitivity congestion so in some sense
we can view the sensitivity as a measure
of how smooth a boolean function is we
respect to the Hamming distance so in
other word if you have function which
has low sensitivity
it means respect to the Hamming distance
is mostly so if there's a nativity
congestus true then just tells you only
if you have a smooth or low sensitivity
function that is easy to compute in some
of the conventional models like the
decision tree model mathematically is
also interesting because you can argue
that a low sensitivity function or
smooth function should have low
algebraic degree okay so now what what
what do we know about this entity a
conjecture so here I list all the
results before June 2019 and so the
first list is about upper bounds on the
process utility and the second list is
about the best construction with no
separating these two last images so
Simon in 1983 rubber ball which is
essentially for ^ effectivity and in
2004 Kenya including improve this
constant form to e and then it was this
constant was later improved by Ambani's
bavarian town mouse when enjoying 2013 -
- but if you look at all this monster or
exponent so in the sensitivity and for
the separations for rubenstein function
if you do the calculation carefully you
can see the process TB is equal to half
the sensitivity Square and so here if
you care but I mean if you carefully
play with the parity of M then you will
be able to get a construction by visa in
2011 so improve this by linear term and
there are bunnies in 2011 introduced a
different construction and improve the
constant factor from 100 to sir so
basically or the bounds are exponential
and other separations are quadratic so
now let me mention the real reason that
I go into this business of sensitivity
college that's because there's the so
I'm accommodate tourists and that's
because simply beautiful crisp on fence
established by Cosman linear in 1992 so
they prove the following so these two
statements are equivalent for any
monotone function age so the first
statement is now let's consider qn so
two ends n-dimensional hypercube graph
so the definition is the following so
the vertices are all the n-dimensional
binary strings or you can think of them
as subsets success of 1 to n so 2 bodies
is adjacent if and only if these two
strings or two vectors differing exactly
one chord in me so for John comb is
equal to 1 the scale single edge kicker
or ever can be going to vertices and
when a is equal to 2 you get a cycle and
when n is equal to 3 that's the cube
that we're all familiar with ok so now
the first time is for every induced
across age of the n-dimensional
hypercube graph such that it does not
contain exactly half the vertices
ok so basically here we are looking at a
partition of the vertices of QN and this
partition cannot be balanced this means
you cannot have exactly half on one side
and half on the other side so now what
were interested in is the maximum degree
of the induced subgraph qn from h and
the induced sub graph on h complement
now if
we can always guarantee that the masked
one of this maximum degree is great or
equal to a function in the dimension of
the hypercube then we can immediately
conclude that for every boolean function
f it sensitivity is greater or equal to
H of the degree of F and this too is
your equivalent okay so let's see why
this is related to a sensitivity
congestion so suppose we can prove
statement one for a function H which is
M to the C for some called positive C
then they've been priced at for every
boolean function sensitivity is greater
or equal to the equivalent of this power
but we already know that the degree and
the block sensitivity and a bunch of
other complexity measures are all
polynomial related and the sensitivity
is already quit it's already less or you
go to the plus acitivity then from this
second statement we immediately know
that sensitivity is also Pournami
related to the other compressed
evangelists and let me spend maybe five
minutes to explain the proof of this
Cosmin so it is a misspelling here
Cosman linear correspondence so
basically they introduced a intermedia
statement let me call this three so
instead of looking at all the boolean
functions they only look at the boolean
functions of degree n where n is the
number of variables and now so they can
show that one two three or equivalent
masses will only care about like how to
prove there's any TV conjecture so we
just need to use the direction from 1 to
2 and the way it was is you prove 1 in
price 3 in price - ok ok so now let me
and I spent the most difficult step in
this proof 1 in price 3 so will I - so
that if we have a function H
bounding this mesm of the maximum degree
in the hybrid view then we have up we
have inequality of bubbly and functions
of 4 degree okay so now let's free by
contradiction suppose 3 doesn't hold it
means that we can fly the boolean
function G such that it has 4 degree
and the sensitivity is smaller than a
shove so here we can assume that the
boolean function is match the other one
to the end 2-1 one misstep zero one so
it doesn't really change the nature of
the problem okay so now let's introduce
of boolean function P of s called the
parity function so basically you just
count the sum of the coordinates and
chat with us even know hold now with
this boolean function we could divide a
subset of vertices of the hypercube let
me call this edge and the subset of
vertices consists of those X such that G
of s times P of s is equal to 1 but
basically multiply the parity function
with the current boolean thumbs with and
you take those that gives you 1 and
thatõs gives you minus 1 to form this
part is true so now one can easily check
that the sensitivity of the boolean
function is equal to the maximum of this
method equals the following this follows
from the definition and what's more
interesting is if you count the number
bodies in h minus the number vertices in
each Countryman's
against it is exactly equal to the
expected value of G times T just from
the definition and by Fourier transform
this is equal to the fullest response it
has P evaluated on the empty set and
this is equal to Chi health M and you
can see that this has to be nonzero
because she has full degree ok so what
does this imply so we just get an
unbalanced partition H H bar and such
that the maximum of this mesm degrees of
induced circulation H bar it's really
smaller than H of them so this will buy
a late statement one so just finish to
prove that one implies three every three
three implies to add simple exercise
there's only one way to prove it to you
okay so with the gozman linear and crisp
on beds so I didn't know that
if we can prove some purely
combinatorial result on the hypercube
then we can possibly set all the same
evilly congestion but here the problem
was a bit complicated because we have to
look at unbalanced partition and we look
at two subclass and it's difficult I
mean at least for me to simultaneously
considered induced sub cost and I mean
if to count number of edges mine seems
impossible so why don't we just look at
one sub graph and of course the metal
object here is to look at a larger
circle right because if you have
unbalanced parties what the mean square
size at least two to the MS 1 plus 1 so
is it true that as long as we take one
more but less than half then we can
already have the Messam degree of
induced subgraph to be at least some n
to the C ok let's play with some small
impose so here I did not draw the
two-dimensional case but you see if we
have a cycle ends before and if we only
take two vertices then with the hepburn
empty induced aqua right but as long as
we take three vertices then we must have
a so basically a passive lines too so it
has the birth has of degree 2
ok and now let's move on to the
three-dimensional case so there are a
what is this
so if we take all the even vertices and
let's say we take one odd works then
this gives you the odd word test has
degree 3 which is not very good for us
right because we basically want to
minimize the maximum degree but there's
a different way of taking 5 vertices
here so we can take all this red
vertices so in the graph so in this in
this beaker and then the induce acquires
a path of length 4 so every vertex has
degree have moved to so now I mean we
can easily prove that it's the best you
can do now let's move to the 4
dimensional case they're already too
many cases to be checked by help but I
mean
computer can handle eyes 6 teams was 9
perfectly well so if you list all the
possibilities and
in the end it will tell you that there
exists a way of choosing night but is
such that induce of course mesm degree -
so a might not be easy to see what did
this nine bodies skips but let me show
this induced of God through you so
basically if they do sucker has one
isolated vertex here and a psycho blonde
state so every bird has test mesm degree
so it has degree at most two and again
that's the best we could do and I mean
the commuter can still handle the next
case this study was seventeen and the
answer it becomes three now so okay so
let's say define our sequence of numbers
so a 2 is equal to 2 X 3 is equal to a
force equal to 2 is 5 equal to 3 then
what's your guess
so it's a be square root of M and
actually transfer a deep gram and see my
1980 a they prove upper bound
meaning that you know M dimensional
hyper cube graph one could find one
mobile test and half such that the mass
M thick will be induced subgraphs will
repair and the construction is the
following so I don't do any details why
this works but if you are familiar with
this M of all function then it basically
tells you that you just multiply this M
of all function with the boolean
function with a beta function and that's
the construction folder so for this in
your sock off and on the other hand they
could show that our no matter which two
to the M minus one plus one word has
induced sub call you choose the mass M
degrees at least log n so now here from
these two theorems
you see some very familiar things right
in the first one there's a quadratic
separation that comes from my example
and the second one you have an exponent
so upper bound so if you still remember
the Gossman linea correspondence so the
second result basically says that
there's a exponential inequality
relating the degree and the sensitivity
and the first one does not precisely
crisp on to rubenstein function the
actually says that if you take this end
of off
function then there's a quadratic
separation between the degree and the
sensitivity
okay so let me hear briefly mention how
they approve this lock and World Bank
first light they look they use I so
pretty much inequality and to some
clever double context and it turns out
that we can actually improve this lower
bound from lock n2 square pen which
would prove the sensitivity conjecture
so we can actually get a very tight bond
which are coincide with the construction
they have which that that comes from
this end of all function so we saw that
for every 2 to the N minus 1 plus 1
versus induce aqua the mesm degrees at
least root and from the gozman linear
correspondence this gives you the
sensitivity is at least square law of
the degree and now if you care about
sensitivity vs + NT t bt in the original
nice and cicada congestion then you can
use this point omean relations between
the boss in TV and degree so nice Anza
get in 92 sold the processing team in
his body from the bar by 2 times the
squared the degree then obviously
improve this to the square of the degree
and recently as a greater student MIT
check where ins improve is constant
further to value of 2 over 3 so now i
can conclude that the process give ities
at most i think two over three times the
degree to the times the sensitivity to
the fourth power ok so now let me cook
it this is quite approve so it's not
quite frequent that you can give in the
food you know one hour talk so the first
idea is instead of looking at the messin
big we obtain your sucker
we could consider the largest eigen pair
and what's the motivation of considering
the largest eigenvalue okay so to build
a massive degree so the most natural
ways can actually bound every degree of
the induce aqua but if you spend two
minutes on this you could quickly see
that it doesn't work right so for
example if you take all the even
vertices and just one audible
then what does the induce sub graph look
like we have the odd vertex adjacent to
em even vertices and you also had a lot
of isolated vertices so so so you get a
star with energies so what's the largest
degree of a star and which is good for
us and but the average degree of this
induced sub core is something like n
over 2 to the M right because there are
only n edges and there's just so many
vertices so the average degree is
actually very small so we cannot expect
to bond to the average degree from below
by N to the C but course you can try to
let's say 10 the sum of the square of
the degrees or maybe even the cubic
powers and so on and then this Ness will
leads you to look at something about the
special norm of the adjacency matrix so
it turns out that the largest eigen
value of the adjacency matrix of the
gratia so let me briefly mention what
adjacency matrix is so for every n bird
has undirected graph we can define our n
by n matrix in the following way so
every row and column corresponds to a
vertex of G and you put n sheet to be
one if these two bodies is adjacent and
you make it zero it don't know Jason so
it's a symmetric n by n matrix so all
the eigen values are real and you can
look at the largest eigen pair which is
lambda one and it turns out that lambda
one is actually between the mesm degree
and every stick and now if you look back
at this example of taking all the heben
vertices and just one old border you can
calculate that largest eigenvalue is
equal to square of them list still good
for us and if you taking a little bit
more you actually see that the largest
eigen value is always polynomially
related to the mesm degree why is that
okay let's start from the easier the
rest kappa bunk so we take the largest
eigen pair lambda 1 and we look at I
came back to view of it and let's just
assume
that VI is the cording name which has
the largest eigenvalue largest absolute
value now by definition we have lambda
one times VI is equal to the I scored in
a of the adjacency matrix of three times
B the what what what does this look like
so this is equal to the sum of bj for
those vertices trail Jason to Y now we
can apply the triangle inequality so
this sum is bounded from above by the
number of coordinates in Bob here which
is the message that the degree of tray
which is bounded from above by the mess
and equally times the upper bound on the
absolute value of BJ so here you can it
is to be stupid FBI because we already
assumed VI gives you the largest one
okay so these two 16 cancels then you
get lambda wise less or you go to the
mess and degree and the other box also
not super difficult to get so you can
answer it delete edge is one by one so
that's one way of defining the largest
eigen value from the Rayleigh quotient
so basically the largest eigen value of
a smashing matrix is equal to s
transpose times the matrix times X
maximize over order are unit vectors so
now once you remove the edges this
maximum can only go down now just delete
all the edges not adjacent to the virtus
vertex of the largest degree and the end
you just get basically a star of the
create Delta and I can vary up this dies
equal to the largest my school of Delta
and the smallest much - school or Delta
and a bunch of zeros so in other words
it tells you that before removing all
these edges not incident to the vertex
of massive degree the eigen pair lambda
one has to be great or equal to squirrel
the method okay so we know that these
two nodes and soprano me related a
minister if we like to use the Gausman
linear correspondence to establish the
sensitivity congestion we really have to
show that the largest eigenvalue
is always great or equal to m to the sea
and is to get the time at the base of
the cube and there's one more advantage
of using the eigenvalue dimension so
because eigenvalue has a very nice
interlacing property so there is this
theorem by Corsi called the cross is
little a theorem so you have to make two
matrices FB so a so M by n symmetric
matrix and B it was the principal
summation so it meaning that if you take
the third fifth and sixth row then you
also take the third fifth and sixth call
and they look at a three by three matrix
if form now let's list all the
eigenvalues of a in the descending order
and I can vary in descending order then
you have the following inequality some
new is less or equal to lambda I realize
greater or equal to lambda I plus M
minus M so is that I cannot really
memorize the exact form of this
inequality but it's easier to think in
this way so if you look at the ice
largest eigenvalue of the smaller matrix
it's bounded from above by the ice
largest I can build up the bigger matrix
if you look at the J smallest eigenvalue
up the smaller matrix its body from
below by the smallest eigenvalue larger
matrix okay and you just need to prove
one and the other one follows by
multiply the basis by -1 and so here let
me mention something you learn relevant
to the conjecture but it's something
that motivates our use of this
interlacing mess so from the causes
interlace year we can already get that
the independence number of any craft so
here the independence number is defined
as the massive number vertices in your
graph such that this vertices are
pairwise non-adjacent so with the fall
in called inertial point on the
independence number there's less or
equal to the number of non negative
eigenvalues of these adjacency matrix is
also less or equal to the number of non
positive eigenvalues of association c
matrix and there are some beautiful
applications of this inertial bound for
example if you notice are this corrado
serum in
one sec Siri is a spirited construct a
graph is adjacency matrix I apply this
bond that he will prove this year all
right then why don't I do the same for
our problem let's just take the
hypercube graph so the haven't you
called again let me leave my what is
this so in the one dimensional case you
just have an edge in a two terminal case
is the fourth icon so you time is no
case it just Q so if we can calculate
eigen value of QN I think that's a
well-known reader in the literature so
it has n this thing sorry M plus 1
distinct eigen values n m- pool and mass
4 and minus 6 all the way down to minus
n so every time you jump by 2 and the
multiplicity of this eigen values are n
choose 0 n choose 1 answers to interest
islands with I can choose them so it's
not so surprising to see that the some
of the oldest binomial coefficients is
equal to 2 to the N which is the number
bodices okay so now let's try to apply
this causes interlace your interpreter
so recall that we're interested in
bounding the maximum degree of 2 to the
M minus 1 plus 1 where it has induced
subgraph of the queue and we already
said that we would like to study the
largest eigenvalue in step MSM tick we
go from the closest interlace theorem we
have a lower bound on lambda 1 of H
which comes from the 2 to the N minus 1
largest eigen value of the original
hypercube ok so if we look at this list
of eigen values we can see this is not
very good for us because you have
mm-must to and in the middle you get may
be either 0 or 1 so this only gives the
more about that the largest eigen value
this includes of course at least 0 or 1
okay so we know that the massive
decrease at is 0 but that should be
right because the independence number of
that of the hypercube curve is only 2 to
the N minus 1 so it doesn't tell us
anything interesting however if you look
at this more carefully you can see that
if we relax
our assumption on the number bodies is a
little bit if we allow to help 1/2 + 3
times 2 to the M word is this so
slightly more than half then the mass M
degree is already greater or equal to C
prime times school or just by I mean you
can just buy these properties of this
binomial coefficient or you can say that
you already mentioned that there's a
which is sleeping area I'm not saying
that is the best you can get by student
the way you get free from the
interlacing you see there's still some
content so building this mess that's the
point yeah thanks all right so we know
that taking the adjacency matrix of Q
and doesn't work here but why don't we
choose a different type of adjacency
matrix so in more combinatoric whenever
you need to prove upper bound that
independence none you can take adjacency
matrix directly and try to apply either
inertia bomb or there's something else
called Horton or you can look at the low
bisetta function and so but use it for
those problems you can also allow to
change the nonzero entries of your
adjacency matrix so here we can use a
similar idea so instead of taking a
usual adjacency matrix of the cube graph
we can tell you something called site
adjacency matrix of the cube so I mean
by style Jason C matrix so I Minster I
keep the zero energy and I can change
the one energy to either 1 or minus 1
but here I need to maintain that matrix
is symmetric
otherwise the consistent Alessio might
not work but you might not even have all
the eigenvalues to be real okay and
turns out that if you have a graph and
you take a so called symmetric side of
Jason C matrix of it then you still have
the same inequality the largest
eigenvalue is still a lower bound on the
mesm degree and the
before I show in the previous pro I
don't even need to take a lot of
absolute values and the reason they roll
in that way is to make sure that it was
key okay so now this means if we can
find a sign signing of the adjacent C
matrix of the cube such that 2 to the M
minus ones largest eigenvalue is equal
to square root n then we are done we
just apply the previous inequality the
largest eigenvalue up the inducer is
greater or equal to the largest eigen
value of this i adjacency matrix and and
in a lacy square you go to this two to
the Emma and it's one largest eigenvalue
up the entire cider adjacency matrix
which is curve of them now the question
is does there exist a so nice cyberchase
and signatures and the answers yes so
let's look at the simplest case so for
the one amongst case there's not too
much choices right I mean you can you
can either put 0 1 1 0 or 0 minus 1
minus 1 0 but the other thing that's
because if you flip the signing on all
the edges incident to a protest that
does not change the eigen value of 5
adjacency matrix and nullified balusters
do to pick my district cursive Lee and
for the next case we will make some
change so it's term having a positive
signing on every edge we only have
positive signs on three edges and one
negative sign and this one remaining
edge and in the next case
there's something very similar but on
the so we have two sub Q's on the first
sub Q we just use whatever we have from
the n minus 1 dimensional depth and for
the bottom sub q which was flipped this
signing and for the vertical edges or
stayed a positive sign so we feel
varieties in the linear super language
the recyclers reason cement you justify
us this M is equal to this 2 by 2 plus
mm minus 1 here identity measures at an
image is - mm - world
so basically needs to identity meshes
responds to the vertical edges and this
tool corresponds to the signing on the
top and importantly
okay so now we can show that if you
square this matrix mm then by a little
bit of calculation this is exactly equal
to n times identity matrix so in other
word you have a symmetric matrix whose
square is equal to M times I so you know
that all the eigen value has to be
either square of M or minus square of M
but by the definition of this matrix the
diagonal entries are all zero so the
trace of this matrix is zero which means
the sum of the eigenvalues has to be
zero as well so if you have a bunch of
square root N and - cool and whose thumb
is equal to the load and the numbers
match so then exactly 2 to the N minus 1
square of n + 2 - MS 1 - squirrel and
this is exactly what we look for
okay so that basically concludes the
proof of the scientific conjecture but
let me miss a little bit so since the
paper is out maybe we'll ask who happens
about the signing is there anything
unique about it can we choose a
different signing and the answer is yes
and no so but I can actually give you a
catalyzation of all the signings that
work here and also the expressed to you
why we only take plus minus 1 instead of
taking other numbers let's say between
minus 1 and 1 so there's this Adamas
inequality in linear algebra it says
that if you take an N by M matrix
I don't think here you need this to be
symmetric then the determinant of this
matrix has absolute value bounded above
by the proton of the length of the road
and and is easier to understand me
geometrically so it just says that the
volume is less or equal to the product
of the side lengths and from there is
not so difficult to see the equalities
which should be fair only if all the row
vectors are pairwise orthogonal ok let's
try to recall what we need for this side
adjacent images M so first of all has to
be Saturday since the matrix meaning
that so ok so what's a use
Jace's images of children so there are
two to the n rows and columns and on
every row or column you see M one and
the rest are 0 so if you take a side
adjacency matrix then the length of this
rose has to be exactly square of M I'm
even if you're allowed to K some number
between minus 1 1 the lesser bounded
from above but by Adamas equality they
determine nice body from above by square
of M to the power 2 to the N and on the
other hand we really want to the M must
once largest eigen value to be large
let's say if we would like to get a
tight result we need this to be at least
square of M so how does the eigenvalues
be half so across the real world the
most well-known results if you take a
bipartite graph then the eigen value of
its position C matrix is symmetric about
0 meaning that if you have lambda I can
tell you the minus lambda is also a
negative so here if you take a side
symmetric made outside adjacency matrix
of the bipartite graph this hypercube
then you still have the same property so
you have 2 to the n eigenvalues 2 to the
M minus 1 of them a positive may be
non-negative and to the MS of one of
them are negative and you need a 2 to
the M minus 1 largest one to be at least
square root M so the only possibility is
the Pope or the positive ones are at
least square of M and all the negative
ones are at most - squirrel there so all
the absolute values and this square of
them so if you so okay so the
determinant is equal to the product
eigenvalues so it has to be at least
column n to the power 2 to Lydia so ok
so we need this Adamas inequality to be
strapped in other word we need other row
backers a pairwise or so to know so in
the m transpose times n to be this is
identity matrix times m now you can do a
little bit of calculation so you write
this as 2 by 2 is corresponds to M minus
1 dimensional sub Q seek response to the
other sub Q and K has to be a diagonal
made
with science and I do a little bit of
calculation in the end it turns out that
the signing K and B will uniquely
determine C and so if you take K to be a
positive and this is exactly how we
defined this earlier and I mean this
will give you all the possible signings
and in the end I see you will see that
all the so there's only one signing up
to it's also if you allow to change or
the size of edges incident to a bullet
exits simultaneously okay
I saw that a couple of chorus extensions
of this sensitivity concert admit that
comes from the proof so we can define a
sensitivity craft RIA is the following
so the bird has said is 0-1 to the pen
and two bodies the adjacent if these two
backers differ in one coordinate and F
values are different so now the special
sensitivity lambda F is defined as just
the largest eigen value of the adjacency
matrix of cheetah
so from the proof we can slightly modify
the proof and so that for all boolean
functions F the degree of F is less or
equal to the square of lambda F so
basically I'll prove this until you can
judge the slider decrease less or equal
to the square of lambda m and lambda F
is less or equal to the sensitivity of F
so from Dave get a degrees less equal to
unity school and you can also you can
either use this black box or you can
look at the proof directly and so
therefore all brilliant functions the
degree is less or equal to the zero
sensitivity times the wine sensitivity
so here this SD log F meaning means that
you just maximize the local sensitivity
over the zero inputs and he'll do it for
the one input right so before I finish
so let me mention there's some remaining
problems in this field so the first one
is I mean still unsolved because so we
only saw that the process itty-bitty
at most some constant times the
sensitivity to the fourth power so Kevin
actually proved that is quadratic almost
quadratic so as since that people have
put a lot of effort in improving the
Rubenstein's construction but so if I
it's hard to play the quadratic barrier
and I also have full face on a variety
of this conjecture and I think maybe one
can actually again use a linear algebra
technique here
so here this is my conjecture that would
imply this QSC so if we look at this
Adamo type matrix mmm now you take a
principal summation and you make sure
that you always pick those rows
corresponding cool give beliefs of
distance obsessed and that he of them
and you make sure they don't include a
roast that responds to the empty set is
it true that has eigen value of absolute
value at move a lot at minus T so this
to now even price the this upper bound
and I cannot even prove it for the
simplest case like equals one or two but
I run a program for small M reasons to
be correct and this for those cases and
I think there is some difficulty of
applying the interlacing here because
for interlacing we can not say that we
want to make sure that certain rows or
columns exist in the principal sub
matrix we take so I don't know how to
create maybe there's a crabber wait
barrier here so the second problem is
more open-ended so for grouchy let's
assume that the course many protests
transitive
or else by symmetric what can we serve
Bob is a far cross one boat has induced
of course so here are fast the
independence number so we didn't know
that this induce sub graph cannot be
empty but can we sometimes get some
non-trivial lower bound imagine between
every degree or the special radius of
this induce sub graph so for example if
you take the Cartesian product of cycles
of less three tell you my something
similar to happen there I if you look at
that
I am flawed that the independence number
is equal to 3 to the 1/2 minus 1 so am I
hope that ok as long as we it takes me
to the MS 1 plus 1 vertices maybe just
like - fill case immediately we have
Messam degree at this root m but
unfortunately it's not even true there
so you can find us 3 to the MS 1 + 1
Bertha Stockwell this condition for tau
3 cycles such that it gives you just an
induce match which is somewhat
surprising to us okay and finally again
this is not a very well formulated
question so so this the choice of this
side adjacency measures can be viewed as
certain operations on the adjacency
matrix of Q and itself such that so we
know that originally QN has addresses so
this pertinency matrix has eigenvalues
they are m and minus 2 and minus 4 all
the way to minus n so in some sense this
finding compresses the positive and the
negative eigenvalues of QM so I'm one
day one can observe this phenomenon
emotional way so can we define some
signing on certain curve such that you
always compresses the eigenvalue IC
would be useful for other problems in
theoretical color science and community
colleges and thank you and this is X
also in the Senate EBT has finally to
endure large and heavy flock thank you
okay and you made me go back to the
question on the block sensitivity I'm
not sure that I can you explain why yeah
okay so I think if we take this sub
matrix MN and so basically we would like
to look at a partition of the vertices
of the cube right and we bout the
maximum degree of that by that I got in
the induced by particle and because this
matrix M is orthogonal orthogonal matrix
so it will the probabilities laid to
induce translate to a principal sub
matrix there only responds to one part
of asperities and that's where this
comes so I just try to take a different
signing of the edges and stuff
setting up them to be one and use the
largest eigen value to burn the messing
degree but now we're doing this for the
bipartite directly and we don't apply
the parity function to to reduce these
to the into the Aqua the basic I don't
want to go through that step of using
increase sorry it's not quite clear to
mr. like well so can you explain this
the principal sub matrices what do you
mean they're coming from these disjoint
sets as one opacity okay so basically
I'm in row and column of this matrix and
then corresponds to a subset so now we
have a fixed list of subsets ex-wife -
ah - st and a pairwise disjoint so now
we're allowed to take any principal sub
matrix using rows I mean we must include
those rows but we're not allowed to use
empties I mean this is life you try to
make sure that a positivity st yeah
basically
and now the eigen value of this matrix
is somehow corresponds to the eigen
value of this bipartite induce of God
and yeah it's less I've written down
more details but yes sort of a little
bit orthogonal but the question about
the best possible signing so if you had
a degree D graph you'd expect the in
there are signings one could expect in a
random graph which Ramanujan like to to
D minus 1 somehow to root n minus one
might have been the limit here but
somehow route and seem to be their limit
for some particular car you can do
better than two thumbs for use of t
regressing the best they will be live is
lateral to the school of the minister I
mean there's this beautiful conjecture
icing by Baloo and Linea so if that's
true then in price that you can
Christopher - bye-bye Potter or maybe
the ramanuja degree justify Ottawa but
isn't root and smaller than 2 root n
minus 1 somehow yeah the sunning is the
finest mentum there's a good
questionable call the public but I don't
see
[Music]
any other questions okay so we take a
10-minute break now and reconvene at
11:10 for the second half of the talk
and maybe some questions for how if we
have something Thanks thank you